لكتائب القسام تتحدث عن ان مقاتله
اسرائيليه استهدفت دبابه وسحقت بمن فيها
لمنع
احتجاج جنود او جثث هل هناك اي تعليق او
ردود فعل حول هذه الروايه في
اسرائيل ليس بعد لكن دعينا نشير فقط الى
ان عمليه التفجير التي ادت الى مقتل هذا
العدد الكبير من عفوا من الجنود والضباط
الاسرائيليين يوم امس ايه كانت ايضا قد
تبعها قصف مدفعي شديد وغارات جويه عنيفه
عن المنطقه او في المنطقه التي وقع فيها
هذا الانفجار الشديد وكنا شهودا على ذلك
يوم امس في حدود الساعه الرابعه مساء
بالتوقيت المحلي الخامسه بتوقيت بتوقيت
مكه المكرمه وبالتالي كان هنالك انفجار
كبير في تلك المناطق وهي منطقه قريبه جدا
من السياج الامني ونحن كنا قريبين جدا من
موقع التفجير تبع ذلك بحقيقه الامر تحليق
كثيف للطيران الحربي الاسرائيلي في اجواء
المنطقه واغار على مواقع قريبه من السياج
الامني وكنا قد اشرنا الى ذلك وتبع ذلك
ايضا قصف مدفعي شديد استهدف تحديدا
المنطقه التي صدر منها هذا الانفجار الذي
ادى الى مقتل هذا العدد الكبير من الجنود
والضباط الاسرائيليين اذا بدا الامر بحدود
الساعه الرابعه
كان هنالك انفجار شديد شد هز هذه المنطقه
الذي وجدنا فيها انا والزميل لبيب بمفردنا
وتبع ذلك حقيقه عقب هذا الانفجار تحليق
مكثف للطيران الحربي الاسرائيلي وغارات
متتاليه على منطقه المغازي وكنا نشير الى
ذلك بالاخبار العاجله وايضا قصف مدفعي
مركز ومتتالي على المنطقه التي وقع فيها
الانفجار نحن نتحدث عن منطقه قريبه جدا من
من السياج الامني التقديرات تشير الى انها
لا تبعد سوى 600 م ونحن نتحدث بالفعل عن
تلك المناطق التي كنا قد رصدناها من منطقه
غلاف غزه في الاسابيع الماضيه والتي يتعمد
الجيش الاسرائيلي الى تدمير البنى التحتيه
الفلسطينيه المنشات التجاريه والصناعيه
والمنازل الخاصه بالفلسطينيين تلك القريبه
من السياج الامني في اطار عمليه اييه
تعريه هذه المنطقه وهدم كل المنازل فيها
واقامه ما ربما تخطط له اسرائيل بعد
انتهاء هذه الحرب وهي اقامه المنطقه
العازله حول قطاع غزه من اجل خلق ربما عمق
استراتيجي او عمق امني يوفر امنا للسكان
الاسرائيليين في منطقه غلاف غزه تحديدا
عند المناطق القريبه من البلدات
الاسرائيليه في منطقه غلاف غزه وهذا ما
كان يشير اليه صباح هذا اليوم المتحدث
العسكري الاسرائيلي بان هذه العمليه جاءت
في اطار جهود الجيش الاسرائيلي لتامين ما
سماها عوده الاسرائيليين الى منازلهم في
بلدات غلاف غزه اذا عمليه التفجير هذه
كانت تستهدف كما قلنا مبان قريبه من
السياج الامني يبدو انها تبعد بنحو 600
متر بحسب التقديرات العسكريه الاسرائيليه
عن السياج الامني ونحن كنا قد كشفنا في
منطقه الشجاعيه والمناطق الواسعه في شرق
مدينه غزه والمناطق الشرقيه تحديدا ايه من
التجمعات السكنيه الفلسطينيه القريبه من
السياج الامني حجم الدمار الهائل الممنهج
الذي قامت به اسرائيل وقام به الجيش
الاسرائيلي في الاسابيع الماضيه في اطار
خلق هذه المنطقه العازله الان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يقول بان القوات الاسرائيليه
وهي قوات تابعه لوحدات الهندسه والوحدات
ال اللوجستيه ال المدرعه كان كانت في مهمه
تفخيخ بعض المباني القريبه من السياج
الامني استعدادا
لتفجيرها وكانت هنالك بطبيعه الحال وحدات
من المدرعات التي كانت تحيط بالموقع الذي
سوف يستهدف
بالتفجير المجموعه مجموعه الجنود والضباط
الذين قتلوا في عمليه التفجير كانوا قد
اعدوا هذه المباني لتفجيرها وكما يبدو ان
كميه المتفجرات التي وضعوها في تلك
المباري المباني كانت كبيره وهائل اي
دبابه اسرائيليه كانت موجوده في تلك
المنطقه تعرضت لصاروخ ار بي جي اطلقته
المقاومه الفلسطينيه التقديرات لدى الجيش
الاسرائيلي تشير الى ان جنديين اسرائيليين
على الاقل قتلا داخل الدبابه بعد
استهدافها بقذيفه ار بي جي و قذيفه اخ
اخرى اطلقت على المبنى الذي كان معد
للتفخيم مما ادى الى انفجار هائل و و كبير
كان بامكاننا حتى ان نشاهده من منطقه غلاف
غزه وهذا بفعل المتفجرات يبدو الكبيره
والكميه الهائله من المتفجرات التي وضعت
في هذه المنازل من اجل تفجيرها ويبدو ان
قذيفه الار بي جي هي التي ادت الى انفجار
او تفجير العبوات الناسفه التي كانت
موضوعه في هذه المباني هذا يفسر حجم
الدمار الكبير انهيار المبنيين المستهدفين
في عمل
التفجير على رؤوس الضباط والجنود واستغراق
الجيش الاسرائيلي لساعات طويله خلال ساعات
الليل من اجل انتشال جثث جنوده وضباطه
الموجودين تحت الانقاد بعد رفعها الجيش
الاسرائيلي اعلن حتى الان اسماء عشره من
جنوده وضباطه الذين قتلوا في هذه العمليه
وهو يستعد للاعلان عن مزيد من الا الاسماء
في قادم الساعات طبعا هنالك من يلوم من
خلال التحليلات العسكريه الجيش الاسرائيلي
على ضروره ان يقوم بمثل هذه العمليات
التفجيريه والتفخيخ وتخط او تشكيل خطر على
حياه جنوده وضباطه وقواته العامله على
الارض في حين كان بامكانه ان يقوم بعمليه
تفجير هذه من خلال الاستهدافات الجويه لكن
في مقابل ذلك هنالك من يقول بانه لا يمكن
في كل الاحوال تدمير هذه المباني وهذه
التجمعات فقط من خلال استهدافها من الجو
على اعتبار ان القوات الاسرائيليه العامله
على على الارض احيانا تعثر على فتوحات
انفاق وعلى مسارات انفاق هجوميه تحت هذه
المباني السكنيه وبالتالي استهدافها من
الجو لا يؤدي الى تدمير كامل البنيه
التحتيه الموجوده تحت هذه المباني من
فتوحات انفاق او من انفاق هجوميه لذلك هذا
الامر يستدعي قيام خبراء المتفجرات ووحده
يالوم تحديدا المختصه في عمليه العثور على
ال انفاق الهجوميه وتفجيرها الوصول الى
هذه ال الانفاق الدخول بها ووضع كميات
كبيره من المتفجرات فيها وتفجيرها هي وما
فوقها ايضا من مبان سكنيه او
منشات اخرى لذلك هذا الامر تطلب وجود
القوات الاسرائيليه على الارض وبعدد كبير
من الجنود والضباط ووحدات الهندسه
والوحدات المدرعه التي كانت تؤمن عمليه
التفجير هذه وهذه ليست المره الاولى التي
يقتل فيها جنود اسرائيليون في نكن هذه
الحصيله كانت ربما
الاقل الاقل حقيقه على الجيش الاسرا